welcome to this video I'm playing Oscar
Wilde okay Oscar Wilde let's let's keep
it solid okay maybe not so solid that
line is a yeah something that I play
occasionally to get a little bit more of
a fighting position again c4 g3 stuff ya
see takes is not very exciting but
definitely something that I can play ok
doesn't want to give me the bishops
right no
okay Ruby one ok let's go here to be
ready to block on d5 in case of any
forms kh4
okay nothing particularly wrong with it
okay trade on g7 it's not a big deal the
thing is why I'm pretty relaxed is that
it's not so clear what whites what white
sub plan is in this position in this is
essentially a Queens gambit declined on
exchange variation the cards but
structure and what has two plants there
one is e for which doesn't seem very
likely at the moment the other is before
which which is entirely out of the
picture so I didn't really think that
something terrible what would happen to
me so this is why I'm pretty relaxed
here so let's see can I get rid of that
night maybe let's try to get rid of it
you can go out for that we can see for
quite a bit
maybe it's still playable even though it
is really weakening you have 95 I
dropped back to see eight that's a
fairly no setup 94 I can also take d 4
right why am I not able to take that pot
you don't see it
if people give me a big sent upon I will
take it I'm usually quite conservative
with grabbing material but a default
pawn that's just too tasty yeah the only
thing is not g5 let's not play g5 but
Knight g4 looks fine okay I'm I'm a pawn
up so I don't mind yeah bad bishops
protect good pawns the bishop one CA
this is a good defender okay so also
keep it protected from the side k a five
if it's not a good idea probably that
was my idea I wanted to try to trade
this off
mm yes I can't maybe this 494 next he
has a 5 but I couldn't really do much
about it I didn't play it but i agree i
couldn't do much about it i think with
this i will trade over the night okay
okay that's not the most active move
ever but anyway not much choice oh
that's a good move move active
I probably have to know there's no real
alternative to that okay that's better I
also was really mostly expecting ruchi
five can I go look 50 crew chief or look
just seven it's not helping much can I
do this maybe it's maybe that's a bit
tougher I don't really know
maybe just retreat the rook yeah the
best possible scenario some rook endgame
with a pawn up that would be a draw but
still I have a pawn rockin let's see
what he's doing and that counter play
was kind of what service was annoying
really so I cannot play Bishop e6 here
okay CFC 547 now that's also not winning
upon
time warning
I don't see anything to play for win
this move that looks crazy looks a bit
crazy
it was it was crazy he found f4 bloody
bloody hell what the heck I can do this
right whoopty seven rookie for its pure
coincidence of course didn't see that
before maybe it's not working with at
the moment I don't see why do I really
have never have an extra pawn yeah cool
I mean it is a draw but hey check
getting that evening kind of Quebec it's
a very easy draw but anyway well Arthur
nights it's a he knows the third ranked
defense offered game draw yeah ok man ah
yeah after you blundered that Paul I
should win this but ok he played a good
defense there around here mo I'm think I
think I'm okay really I mean ok anyway I
mean yeah I didn't screw anything up
that's what I'm trying to say but after
be five hit it got difficult so maybe I
have to to improve somewhere before I
don't really know if here if I have
something okay that afore was something
that i did not see of course that was a
key a key idea and the engine gives this
install a pawn yeah I didn't I didn't
really see four and this was a good a
good opportunity for him I was thinking
rook g5 though this I didn't expect but
it is good g5 hangs and c6 hangs so I
think relatively speaking i put and this
time i made it tricky for him
but is it is still a draw fe 5c takes
root cheeks is probably a bit simpler
hey it's a draw anyway check it's a
chaplain yeah okay so i should have won
that with the extra point but i didn't
play it good enough technically thanks
for watching